so what is so wrong with codependency
basically saying that narcissism is bad
but so does codependency what is the
abuse of codependency people like some
simpler dichotomy so we could create one
of a that's a story for you now you
could broadly say that narcissism hurts
other people and broadly say that
codependency hurts the codependent so
they're both maladaptive but the cost
could be outward to the environment or
inward but they're both maladaptive
codependency is originally a it's
non-clinical the clinical the closest
clinical entity we have is dependent
personality disorder but codependency we
all know kind of roughly what it means
but it actually meant somebody who's an
enabling an enabler of an alcoholic and
then there was some american ladies in
the 80s who wrote three big best-selling
books I think one of them was called
women who love too much and all three of
them spoke about codependency from the
point of view of women who stay loves
these women but men as well who stayed
in abusive relationships and that was
called being a co-dependent
I just wrote a book called The Cult of
one hey
um and I I redefined it back to the
original narcissus myth so narcissus is
a Greek mythology he was a beautiful
Greek Hunter
who everybody loved but he refused
everybody but his counterpart in ovid's
version of this myth was called Echo she
was a wood nymph and she lost her voice
as she was cursed by the queen of the
gods as a punishment so she could only
Echo the last three words that somebody
spoke to her she could no longer speak
for herself
so I set up like a paradigm that was you
have narcissism which is toxically Yang
and then Echo codependency which is
toxically Yen they're always on they're
always talking it's all about them
that's toxic
we're always off we're always listening
and it's all about others that's toxic
this is more toxic for the environment
this is more toxic for us but we do also
manipulate people we do also guilt-trip
people where ostentatiously
self-sacrificing and it pushes people to
do things that they that they wouldn't
otherwise do plus the sins of the
codependent now they're on this is we
become bitter because of course if you
give too much and you say that yes to
things you don't want to do you're going
to get cranky and better because we're
hoping like little children instead of
saying I'd like you to do this for me in
reciprocation thing and expect nothing
what we do is we hope we hope and we
don't say what we want you're doing
things hoping for a reaction you're
hoping to get something in return like
even just a thank you you're the best or
I appreciate that or you're so sweet or
whatever it may be
um and also on top of that is a like a
deeper hurt in the manipulation that you
could try and Achieve as a codependent
is that however you feel about me is how
I feel about me yes
and that makes you do things to try and
you know feel better but if but it's
fleeting because it's inconsistent
because it's not you so yeah that makes
perfect sense that the narcissist will
essentially hurt outside of them more
than a codependent a codependent
continues to abandon themselves
over and over again and what they really
want and that's what makes them not real
either to some degree is because you
know like I don't know if this is
something you struggle with but I
remember starting to ask myself the
question what do I want to do today like
what would make me happy today and you
like don't have an answer at first
you're like I don't know whatever you
want to do I want to serve my master
today that's what I want to do because
I'm a slave yeah I know there's there's
what you just said is interesting and it
points back to this key issue with the
codependency and the gnosticism however
you feel about me is however I'm gonna
feel about me this is because
codependency Echo codependency we draw
all of our sense of self from others
which is kind of weird it's parasitic
and we're not really being ourselves
we're showing up but we're not there
we're haunting our own lives this is
also codependent because all of their
sense of self comes from others the
narcissist and codependent were not
allowed to develop a real authentic self
in childhood it was simply verboten so
they never learned how to do it they
don't know how to access it the
narcissist also is in many ways empty
everything they do is for the reactions
they can Garner from other people this
is called narcissistic Supply everything
they do is for narcissistic Supply they
run out of that and they experience a
kind of death they go into real critical
uh collapse if they run out of that
what is an a codependent death is there
an equal and opposite codependent death
that they experience we're more
resilient we're much more resilient in
that regard because
so like I said to you like the false
dichotomy and we love creating twos we
have like a two-party system and there's
two Wings on a bird and we have two eyes
we have two hands we're obsessed I'm
sure if we had three hands as we make
everything into threes so we go here it
is here's the issue on one side and
here's the issue on the other
so I've drawn this comparison between
our system codependence here's a pretty
critical issue and difference for mental
health and this is why codependency
isn't a clinical entity
we're not mad
where when neurotic when neurotic but
not psychotic we're not psychotic
they're psychotic they cannot access
reality on untainted we can codependents
are pretty realistic they can see other
people narcissists can't
codependents don't see themselves very
well narcissists see the codependent
usually better than they see themselves
because there's not much there to see
but our connection with reality is much
better you show me a person who's been
diagnosed like clinically by a clinician
with narcissistic personality disorder
that's a very emotionally disregulated
person you show me somebody who's a
codependent they'll be somewhere on a
sliding scale of depression and anxiety
but they're not they're not jumping out
their skin
um with with real internal suffering
typically not typically and if they are
it's not because of the codependency I
think it's only fair to understand
not only what attracts a narcissist or
something degree but also this isn't a
villainization game of like oh they are
the only bad ones it's trying to
understand how to heal so that these
things don't exist anymore what is it
that needs to be healed the most like
how what is like a macro solution for
this
and my solution
um I'll just say this is 10 years of
just trying to answer the question how
do I get myself out of this and how do I
get my clients out of my clients the
people who follow my material my readers
how do I get break out of this what do
we do if you start teaching
self-assertiveness and boundaries you're
creating more neurosis and what I've
noticed when people do self service
courses and Boundary setting courses it
just makes them belligerent and
confrontational and false and I'm like
this is that's not it so I took it all
the way down to I think the peace elf
and I met somebody who's an artistically
abusive first of all I wouldn't be very
impressed by them I wouldn't be so naive
and impressionable as to believe their
story of who they were
second of all so I wouldn't get involved
with them I just feel like all right
mate nice story see you later second of
all I wouldn't get involved with them
third of all I wouldn't be in a mad rush
to fuse and merge with them if I had a
self because if I have a self
and I have once and I have value system
and I have a morality morality is an
important issue that we have to cover at
some point
it's essential for recovery and to make
sure this doesn't happen again
and I have a philosophy of life and it's
mine
I'm not going to get with people like
this and if somebody slips past the
garden gets in
I won't stay with them and if I'm all
the way in with somebody like somehow I
just fall asleep for three years and I
get married and have kids with somebody
and I am still and I'm that much backed
in into the corner in a battle and I've
got all of that to deal with to get out
how am I going to be able to do it I
must have a functioning self it's the
only way so the good news is if people
come to me now with uh the issue of
codependency haven't been a narcissistic
abuse relationship I'm like hey I'm not
only gonna get you over this
relationship make sure it never happens
again but I believe I can help if I can
take you on the same path I walk down I
can put you back to life because you're
not living and you never were yeah so
you'll actually enjoy your quality of
life that you never had before because
you weren't a person before so then you
moved you don't know who you were
because you you don't know you so how do
you make you happy if you don't even
know you you mentioned a word that I'm
really curious what it means get past
the guard you said if they get past the
guard what is the guard
uh we all have boundaries or we should
do and those boundaries are based on
filters and every once in a while
somebody will get past your filters and
and your perceptual boundaries your
moral boundaries of what you think is
acceptable
um and that's normal
the problem I found with codependence is
we don't have good boundaries we're
either very intimate and close or the
person's a stranger and I was like wow
that's weird I I figured that out one
day with my with one of my clients we
were laughing about it
um she didn't even really speak good
English so we would do therapy and like
broken English and uh I was like oh the
way you are is you're not a house with a
Garden Path and a gate and a road you're
just a bedroom and she's like what do
you mean and I was like Well normally
someone oh they say hi can I come in
then you open the gate they walk up The
Path then they open the door then they
go in the living room and then maybe
they get to go upstairs and then maybe
they go in the bedroom but that's not
happening there's just bedroom there's
no gate there's no door there's no
nothing you have a binary uh state with
your boundaries someone I don't know
someone I'm literally
doing the most physically intimate
things possible with total boundary
lessness and people who live on a
sliding scale of that even if it's not
as severe as that case you can see right
off the bat where that's a problem like
there's you you can't live like that you
have to have multiple degrees of
boundaries and everybody's experienced
that you've got a friend who's a good
friend when they're out there orbiting
out there but you bring them into a
closer orbit doesn't work that doesn't
mean they're a bad friend and you should
get rid of them that just means they
stay in that place where they were
before that's where you keep them that's
somebody you say hi to at the gym that
doesn't mean you're going to go on a
girls holiday with them
so is this indicative of both sort of
polarities
overreaching be overreaching for
intimacy on some level wanting to be
accepted but not ever being able to get
there because you don't know yourself
well enough or you don't love yourself
well enough so it's sort of just this
um it's sort of this Catch-22 that keeps
missing but it's actually a desperate
attempt for intimacy if you like this
clip and you want to hear the whole
episode click at the bottom of your
screen